that John Jones versus Gustafson yeah
I'm stuck on both fights that's all I
want to tell people it's that I wouldn't
bet me I can't bet either he though
they're both very good matchups very
good cyborgs you have to give her an
advantage because she's so much bigger
and because she just doesn't seem to
lose
she's just smashing people she's got
really really good technique and she's
super powerful and she's really big and
she's got a lot of success and then
Amanda Dinah's is without a doubt the
hardest hit in bantamweight she's a
[ __ ] cool Smasher man she's League a
great camp she's maintained long
shoulders long she keeps keep on the end
of punches she'll she's gonna test
cyborg you know we're gonna find out
whether or not she could hurt her and we
find out if she can hurt her this could
get crazy who the [ __ ] knows cuz Amanda
Nunez can crack if she hurts cyborg it
could get crazy but if she can't she
hits harder than Holly I think my humble
opinion I think Holly is a great kicker
and Holly is you know she's really good
at movement and she's very durable and
Holly managed to go the full distance
with cyborg you know there's a hard
fight it was a hard fight and she lost
that fight the difference between Holly
and Amanda núñez I think is like one
shot power is better for núñez but you
know Holly when you she fought Germaine
Gironda me she when she fought Germaine
she knocked her down she knocked you
down with a straight left
she hurt her she hurt her a couple times
she head kicked her she hit her with a
question mark kick and had kicked her
and Germaine de random E is really good
heavy heavy duty Muay Thai fighter but
she didn't want to fight cyborg Holly
did how are just the biggest and the
best in terms of like her you look at
her success ratio you look at what the
way she beats girls down she's so
powerful man but Amanda is the toughest
fighter this is yeah this is if you go
back to cyborgs fight with Gina Carano
Gina Carano one point I was on top of
her on the ground she didn't sustain it
and she lost the fight and cyborg
eventually smashed her but there were
Gina had her moments in that fight you
know and I don't think Gina was ever the
one shot cracker that Amanda is however
cyborg is way better than she was back
then but you know so is Amanda I'm
and you know coming off with Raquel
Pennington fight he watched that fight
she dominated Raquel Pennington I think
Raquel is one of the toughest girls in
the division she's a hard woman and she
she beats a lot of really good fighters
and she she gave Holly Holm all she
could handle and got a split decision
lost Holly Holm in Holly's debut in the
UFC
I mean she's [ __ ] good and Amanda
Nunez handled her it was very very
impressive who's scary like dismantling
she's beating her up I was like wow like
she's on another level now as a champion
she's gotten even better she was always
really good she was always really
dangerous but as a champion she got even
better when she beat Ronda Rousey in 48
seconds that was the big coming-out
party like here we are baby she's she's
the best bantamweight ever you know in
terms of like her or her ability to
knock girls out like she's the scariest
of all time she's the only one I mean
cyborg can't make 135 Amanda Nunez can
she's a legit 135 champion you know and
she's got it down now - she can go five
rounds she can she can beat the [ __ ] out
of you for five rounds now it's
different